Emily Foster une ancienne députée de la
coalition Québec que nous avons appris à
connaître un peu plus l'automne dernier
parce qu'elle était panéliste à notre
émission mordu de campagne Emilie Foster
donc dénonce dans un texte la ligne de
partie l'obligation pour les députés de
voter en bloc pour défendre la position
de leur formation politique c'est
députés sont écrasés c'est ce qu'elle
dit écraser par cette discipline et elle
plaide pour plus de liberté et l'ajoute
qu'on est dans une époque de marketing
politique où les conseillers politiques
prennent beaucoup de place peut-être
même trop de place pas de ligne de
partie le midi avec nos mordu Michel
Cochen Jean-François lisier et Françoise
Boivin Dimitri soudain s'est absent
aujourd'hui bon début d'après-midi à
vous trois bonjour salut alors écoutons
Émilie je me permets de l'appeler Émilie
parce qu'elle était une collaboratrice
de notre émission de fin d'après-midi en
campagne électorale donc Emilie Foster
au final on sait que c'est mieux de
montrer une image unie avec une équipe
unique mais de là en faire sur tous les
enjeux tout le temps systématiquement ça
c'est une autre chose là sur des choses
sensibles comme voter contre un rapport
de commissaire alétique oui moi j'ai eu
un immense malaise j'apprécie beaucoup
pierre
n'était pas d'accord
ok Françoise il me semble de vous voir
dans un caucus de partie vous faire dire
Françoise tu vas voter de telle façon il
me semble que la table en face de vous
doit avoir des égratignures de d'ongle
c'est une ligne de partie est-ce qu'elle
est mauvaise pour la démocratie
je vais vous dire puis croyez-le ou non
ça m'est jamais arrivé puis je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi d'ailleurs j'avais
décidé il y a de cela d'une dizaine
d'années que si j'écrivais mes mémoires
je sais que le titre en anglais
Jean-François pourrait me le traduire ce
serait never about benture jamais député
derrière bas je vais vous dire pourquoi
quand j'ai accepté de me lancer en
politique en 2004 avec l'équipe de Paul
Martin Paul Martin avec qui que ce soit
que c'était réel puis que c'était sa
pensée politique avait décidé de faire
de la réforme démocratique pas seulement
une réforme électorale mais de faire de
la réforme démocratique un point central
de son équipe et moi j'ai embarqué
là-dedans à plein à pleine pleine pleine
complètement parce que ce qu'il voulait
faire c'était exactement ce dont Emily
nous parle dans son texte et dans les
entrevues qu'elle fait
en parenthèse j'ai toujours un petit
malaise que j'entends des anciens
députés qui ont vécu la ligne de partie
qui l'ont accepté qui ont joué le jeu
venir m'écrire des textes après ça sur
comment on devrait faire ou comment on
ne devrait pas faire alors je reviens ma
petite histoire 2004 j'embarque lui ce
qu'il voulait faire pour le Martin il le
fait c'était de créer différents types
de votes c'est à dire les votes de
confiance de pas le choix on était
minoritaire en 2004 on fait tomber
pratiquement n'importe quand d'ailleurs
c'était presque c'était presque au
niveau mental c'était assez hallucinant
parce que c'était dans notre dans notre
miroir c'était devant nous constamment
mais il avait quand même tenu bon même
si on était minoritaire et on avait les
votes de confiance budgétaire et tous
les autres étaient libres selon notre
bon vouloir marcher
et ça a fonctionné mais l'idée est bon
de le faire tout seul c'est ça que je
comprends pas des députés derrière bas
ils sont souvent plus nombreux que les
banquettes avant et dans ce contexte là
ils ont le poids du nombre je sais pas
si c'est mon background de négociatrice
mais moi je m'organise avec ma gang de
5e rangée puis à chaque fois que vous
venez le temps de voter puis qu'on
devait voter on se regroupait on se
parlait puis là il disait Françoise que
c'est une intention de faire et c'est ça
je pense vous avez voté contre votre
partie à la Chambre des communes
à plusieurs repris aucune sanction et ça
c'est l'autre pendant parce que tu peux
pas voir cette politique là mais si
parce que tu le fais puis tu te lèves
après ça on te coupe certains certains
privilèges de caucus ou bien qu'on te
met puis tu le sens que tu es à part et
aussi ce qu'il avait en place pour le
Martin pour pas le nommer c'était des
rencontres avec ses députés derrière bas
à toutes les je pense trois semaines on
allait manger au 24 c'est souvent ils
disaient ces ministres vous auriez
intérêt à parler à ces gens-là qui
arrivent c'est des nouveaux députés pour
la plupart ils arrivent ici ils ont des
bonnes idées je dis ça pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui empêche présentement un
groupe de députés par exemple de la CAQ
au Québec qui sont peut-être une
trentaine de députés qui ont pas
quelques fonctions que ce soit de
simplement dire et on n'est pas on n'est
pas des plantes vertes pour reprendre
l'expression de clairse ensemble on est
ici pour représenter notre population et
ils ont plein d'endroits où ils peuvent
le faire alors moi je m'inscris toujours
quand j'entends ces gens-là de nous dire
la ligne de partie parce que des suiveux
Sébastien parce que des gens qui
acceptent de suivre la ligne de partie
que ça se perpétue en même temps Michel
un député qui sortirait durant en ce
moment là il se ferait bouffer tout rond
par les médias c'est à dire que on
verrait une fissure dans la solidarité
du parti
preuve à l'appui Anthony on en a parlé
cette semaine il a voté contre le projet
de loi c'est très sur les langues
officielles puis on a fait quasiment un
quart d'émission là-dessus à savoir
est-ce qu'il va est-ce qu'il devrait
ranger son passeport il aurait plus de
voyages ce qui peut être exclu du caucus
en même temps il y a cette pression là
sur les partis politiques aussi pour
montrer un front uni non c'est sûr c'est
sûr c'est sûr que les médias
sont un élément important dans la dans
la raison pour laquelle notamment les
bureaux de Premier ministre veulent
s'assurer d'une cohésion et d'une
étanchéité étanchéité à toute épreuve
sur les messages parce qu'effectivement
puis je vais rajouter les médias
traditionnels mais il y a aussi
évidemment le phénomène des médias
sociaux ou
une petite objection va finir par
devenir la crise la manchette et la
crise de la journée au sein même du
parti alors ça demeure un équilibre
aujourd'hui probablement beaucoup plus
difficile à gérer que ce ne l'était mais
sur le fond des choses par ailleurs
c'est évident que les députés doivent
pouvoir
avoir la capacité de s'exprimer en tout
temps surtout projet de gouvernement et
là je fais référence au fait que
effectivement par exemple dans un focus
les ministres ne doivent pas présenter
de projets de loi au Conseil des
ministres sans d'abord avoir été au
caucus et et dans des gros caucus à 90
moi je connais un caucus de 75 je crois
il y a des députés qui ont toujours des
centres d'intérêt bien précis et on peut
réunir un certain nombre de caucus et
dire on vous confie la tâche de vous
asseoir avec le ministre et de vraiment
tourner toutes les pierres du projet de
loi d'argumenter de donner votre opinion
de même faire des vérifications dans vos
circonscriptions je veux dire il y a
moyen de d'avoir des participations
actives ce qu'on sent de la CAQ pas
juste des milliers faster on entend des
bruits de fond est-ce que ça se fait
est-ce que ça se fait de façon
suffisamment structurée et de façon
régulière faut pas faire ça juste une
fois de temps en temps parce que il y a
un dossier qui est plus sensible qu'un
autre il faut que ce soit
systématique et il faut et ça parle du
chef ça c'est le chef du parti le chef
du gouvernement qui doit déterminer ce
rôle des des députés d'arrièrement et
leur capacité d'avoir cette expression
là pour éviter les grognes parce que un
député qui ne peut pas s'exprimer mais
c'est évident qu'ils veulent faire en
catimini ils veulent faire à sa façon et
ça ça soulève la grogne et à 90 députés
c'est plus facile d'aller en chercher 30
qui sont pas contents puis qui sont pas
heureux que quand tu es dans un caucus
plus petit donc faut les garder heureux
faut les impliquer il faut les
responsabiliser à l'intérieur du corps
et c'est faisable et c'est faisable
Jean-François ligne de partie c'est un
mal nécessaire ou c'est une plaie
ça dépend comment c'est géré parce que
je pensais
au bout du compte un gouvernement n'est
que l'organisation de l'opinion de ses
marques je veux dire si un gouvernement
exprime des opinions divergentes
constamment
ça va il cherche leur identité ils ont
pas d'agenda ils ont pas de priorité ils
sont brouillon donc évidemment il y a
une organisation minimale sur les sujets
centraux qui est absolument
indispensable sinon il y a pas de
gouvernement ensuite la liberté de
parole externe des députés
une nouvelle normalité peut être créée
comme le raconte Françoise à partir du
moment où c'est discuté et sanctionné
par le chef que sur un certain nombre de
questions les députés peuvent s'exprimer
publiquement les journalistes sont
surpris des deux premiers jours mais
ensuite ça devient la normalité alors
effectivement nous on a essayé à
différentes reprises on dit sur les
questions morales sur un certain nombre
de trucs on va le laisser mais si on
crée une nouvelle normalité ça devient
normalité mais évidemment sur des sujets
nous notre ex était si c'était dans le
programme du PQ tu as été élu sur le
programme voilà tu changes pas d'avis
mais maintenant c'est une nouvelle
législation on essaie de s'entendre en
cocotte si on s'entend pas on accepte
qui est des divergences ou au minimum
que personne qui compte est obligé de
dire le contraire de ce qui pense il y a
toutes sortes de nuances qu'on peut
utiliser pour aménager la dissidence au
sein de caucus et ça ça suppose et donc
j'ai lu attentivement le texte madame
faster dans option politique et ce
qu'elle semble nous décrire dans la
gestion interne du caucus c'est que les
mêmes est dit que la présence des
conseillers politiques au sein du côté
inhibe la parole des députés ben moi
j'ai eu l'expérience inverse je veux
dire lorsque j'étais conseillé de
Monsieur Parisot
exigé que le chef de cabinet est moi en
soit présent à chaque focus parce que
des fois pas parce qu'il voulait être
certain que non seulement le chef mais
c'est conseillé sachent que le caucus
pensait alors donc je sens que Madame
Fausto est en train de nous décrire un
parti politique la carte qui est
beaucoup plus
restrictif dans la prise de parole
écoutez nous je sais pas ce que ça mes
collègues me diront ce qui se passait
dans leur partie mais lorsque j'étais
chef et même simple député au ministre
on commence le caucus par la revue de la
situation politique et là le chef dit
ben voilà ce qui s'est passé depuis une
semaine je vous informe d'un certain
nombre de choses qui sont pas dans les
médias et maintenant on ouvre la parole
à la situation politique ce qui veut
dire que n'importe quelle député peut
dire n'importe quoi sur l'orientation du
parti du gouvernement comment ça va
qu'est-ce qui va mal pourquoi ça devrait
changer et c'est le bout le plus
intéressant du caucus parce qu'ensuite
on passe à la présentation des projets
de loi et là le
le responsable du projet ou la critique
du projet dit mais voici ce qui est le
projet voici ce qu'on pense les
amendements est-ce qu'on va faire pour
ou contre en première lecture et là la
discussion s'engage là-dessus puis il y
a une décision de cocus à prendre sur
notre attitude face à chaque projet de
loi donc un caucus qui fonctionne
satisfait la volonté d'expression de ses
membres et ensuite dans presque tous les
cas les membres se rallie à la décision
parce que ils ont participé à générer la
décision puis il semble pas que dans
tous les cas dans certains cas
évidemment le chef dit écoutez là-dessus
on en a discuté mais moi j'ai décidé
d'aller dans tel sens si tout le monde
sent qu'ils ont été entendus puis qu'une
fois de temps en temps ils font changer
la position du chef ou du ministre moi
j'ai vu au gouvernement Bouchard en
particulier des cocus tués des projets
de réforme mais vraiment aller tuer
complètement et pourtant le ministre
était pour le chef était encore puis le
caucus voyez allons pouvoir était réel
moi je dis qu'en tout cas dans les
gouvernements du Parti québécois le
lobby le plus puissant à Québec c'était
pas le pétrole les banques ou les
syndicats c'était le caucus québécois et
c'est normal parce que c'est eux les
élus alors donc j'ai l'impression que
Madame fastu nous décrit un caucus qui
n'est pas fonctionné et un parti qui est
très autoritaire qui a plutôt qu'une
culture politique une culture
d'entreprise
Michel il est conseillers au caucus que
vous avez comme sursautés quand
Jean-François abordé cette question là
parce que Émilie Fosseux dit on n'aime
pas ça avoir des conseillers que je veux
vous voyez ça comment mettre la même
façon que Jean-François ce sont des
conseillers du bureau du premier
ministre parce que il y a une
coordination nécessaire à faire entre
tous c'est évident que et quand un
ministre avait un projet de loi à
présenter par exemple elle pouvait
amener son attaché politique responsable
du dossier mais mais c'est évident je
sursaut dans le sens de Jean-François
c'est un moment donné c'est un travail
d'équipe et s'il y avait des il est
arrivé quelquefois le des sujets très
très sensibles qui pouvait mettre en
cause un ministre ou un député à ce
moment-là si tu arrives peut-être deux
trois fois en disant ou là le personnel
était exclu mais c'était pour des
raisons très très très particulière mais
sinon dans le fonctionnement du moment
où les discussions politiques parce
qu'il faut pas oublier une chose le
caucus c'est tellement représentatif
d'une société et ces représentatifs de
toutes les régions ou à peu près toutes
les régions du Québec dépendant du
nombre de députés mais tu as le bout du
terrain et et tu es et c'est en écoutant
ton focus que tu peux très certainement
peser le pour et le compte parce qu'en
politique tu veux pas juste savoir ce
qui fait ton affaire tu vas aussi que tu
écoutes ce qui de ton affaire faut que
tu sais comme ça que tu peux mesurer si
tu prends une bonne décision ou une
mauvaise décision et je suis d'accord
avec Jean-François combien de fois les
ministres ont été obligés de retourner
faire leurs devoirs parce que le caucus
a porté des points de vue extrêmement
pertinents et des discussions de fond
parce qu'on prend des décisions
importantes qui ont des conséquences sur
la vie des citoyens ou sur la vie des
organisations des institutions donc il
faut pas être précis puis quand on a un
moment il faut les allonger les cocus
c'est pas une question non plus si on
est trop pressé il faut en rajouter et
il faut il faut laisser le temps et et
ça il y en a qui sont des premiers
ministres qui sont plus précis que
d'autres mais moi j'ai appris beaucoup
beaucoup
dans la façon de de gérer toute une
équipe pour aller chercher des consensus
et des ralliements il y a plusieurs
députés qui m'ont dit on est on est
capable de s'exprimer au caucus mais
encore faut-il être entendu parce que
des fois il y a des des chefs qui
n'écoutent pas et qui n'entendent pas ce
que leur caucus leur dit parce que leur
idée est faite François je vous laisse
conclure
ce que j'allais dire Michel a parlé
tantôt de l'importance de tête d'avoir
des comités et ça faisait partie de
notre fonctionnement 2004 il y avait
toutes sortes de division c'était
incroyable vous allez me dire ah ben
divisé pour mieux régner pas
nécessairement parce que si tu mets en
place par exemple il y avait la
Commission des femmes à l'intérieur du
Parti libéral du Canada que je présidais
et ça ça combinait les femmes ministres
du parti les femmes sénatrices les
députés femmes et à travers ça on avait
des enjeux et parfois on a on faisait
venir et il venait les ministres par
rapport à certains des enjeux qu'on
avait on avait entre autres le dossier
du bouclier antimicile la commission que
je présidais avait le cocus des femmes
que je puissevais un petit peu de
difficultés avec le concept on a fait
venir le ministre la défense Bill green
à l'époque il y a fait une rencontre
avec les spécialistes du ministère pour
nous expliquer on a maintenu notre
position il y en a on contenu notre
pression sur le gouvernement et
finalement ils l'ont laissé tomber il y
avait un comité ça c'est un focus social
donc toutes les questions de santé etc
étaient discuter là il est ministre
venaient présenter leur projet de loi
c'est comme ça que ça doit se passer une
démocratie à l'intérieur d'un caucus sur
les conseillers j'ai vécu les deux
régimes c'est-à-dire au parti libérale
n'avait pas le droit d'être présent au
caucus au NPD ils avaient le droit
d'être là mais il ne parlait pas ils
observaient pas maintenant
tirs après les réunions pouvaient voir
prendre le pot un petit peu mais au
parti libérale on ne les voulait pas là
parce que c'était le temps où tous les
membres du caucus avaient du top pouvait
prendre le temps d'aller à un des micros
en place pour parler directement au
Premier ministre ou parler à des
ministres sur certaines questions qui
les préoccupaient alors il y a aussi
démocratique qui peut se faire et moi ça
m'inquiète quand j'entends la version
d'Emilie fasters parce que si c'est
comme ça que la CAQ fonctionne il va
falloir qu'il fasse un virage au moment
donné parce que un député là je vais
lire on a tous un certain égo hein et on
se fait élire c'est pas pour faire de la
de la
partition le temps d'affiguration voyons
donc alors ils ont des idées puis des
fois ça vaut la peine de les écouter et
puis on des talents puis peut-être que
les médias si on les habitués à ça ben
peut-être qu'il serait un petit peu
moins enclin à voir oh mon dieu
quelqu'un qui s'exprime qui est pas un
ministre ou le chef d'un parti
Émilie façon on l'a découverte à mordu
de campagne
qui ont parlé jamais quand elle était
député ben merci de nous avoir ouvert
les portes de cette salle du caucus dans
laquelle nous on n'est jamais admis
évidemment et pour savoir un peu comment
ça fonctionne et quels sont les
différentes méthodes de travail pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI